okay so today we've got exclusive access
to and not in forest football ground
here
two-time European Cup winners who have
given us the access so that we can talk
about a very important number in
football and a very important number in
probability which is the number 23
okay so 23 so why is 23 an important
number in football some of you may know
this already that's the number of people
that you will have on the pitch during
the game that's two teams of eleven and
the referee so there are 23 people on
the pitch now here's my question today
what's the probability that two of those
people will share a birthday
the answer may surprise you so we're not
talking about the year we're just
talking about the date itself maybe it's
the 14th of January
maybe it's the 5th of June we're talking
about the date itself so let's work this
out I can make this slightly easier if I
ask the opposite question I'm gonna work
out the opposite which is what's the
probability that no one on that pitch
shares a birthday that's an easier
question to answer let's do this ok so
your first player okay doesn't matter
what birthday he has but when your
second player gets on the pitch what's
the probability that he doesn't share a
birthday well he will have out of the
365 days to choose from he can have a
birthday on 364 of them out of 365 so
we're not including February the 29th no
leap years here and we are assuming that
all days are equally likely ok so your
second player has to have one of these
days your third player when he comes
onto the pitch will have a choice of 363
days out of 365 and then what next the
fourth player out of those remaining
days he will have 362 out of 365 and he
can keep going eventually you'll get to
the 23rd player let's call him the
referee so your 23rd player how many
choices to see how he will eventually
get 343 days left out of 365 so this is
the number of days that you're allowed
to have for that referees birthday
because we are looking at no one sharing
a birthday now if you want to find out
the probability that no one shares a
birthday you multiply all these together
and you'll get number and that number is
roundabout not 0.493
if you're not happy with probabilities
like that that's 49.3% just slightly
under half we were interested in the
opposite question the opposite question
was what's the probability that someone
does share a birthday that's the
opposite thing of what we've worked out
so the probability that someone does
share a birthday
will be 50 0.7% it's slightly over a
half you're more likely to four to place
to share a birthday than if they don't
share a birthday
and that's quite surprising and people
wonder think well it must be something
like a hundred people you must need a
hundred people for that to be true or
200 people if you think of it this way
think of all the pairs of people you can
make we're out of 23 people on the pitch
all the possible pairs of people in fact
there are 253 pairs of people you can
make and well think of it that way you
can start to see why it's quite likely
that two of those people will share a
birthday so next time you're at a
football match think of it there is a
big you have a greater than fifty
percent chance that two of those people
share birthday
okay so here's another way to think
about it imagine you're watching the
game and well if you need to go to the
toilet you get up and you have to move
past all the other people by the time
you've moved past 23 other spectators
there is a greater than 50% chance that
two of those people you've walked past
will have shared a birthday